bang bang what's up lunch money time
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us is trying to get our lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
intelligent looks like she's going to
the beach polina Eve I love a merinov uh
pomp Leone Oh p IM p what up fun fact
this one strap in it was like stop
moving and I apparently didn't stop
moving him and he said pretend you're
dead
hey I've gotta get across it's like
talking to a child so what do you do you
talking child lately all right don't
forget lunch money is now sponsored by
block by block fine has three products
you can buy and sell crypto watch out
get money get paid bitcoin pop it you
can buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and earn a or get a US dollar
loan or you can deposit crypto and earn
up to eight point six percent a py and
an interest-bearing account no-brainer
block five comm slash lunch money
go do it there's risk do your research
but go check out block fight speaking of
Bitcoin what's up with the billionaires
the Billy boys okay happy so a new tax
is being proposed by progressive
lawmakers and activists that would
impose a new form of capital gains tax
on new yorkers with a billion dollars or
more in assets sponsors of the plan say
it would raise 5.5 billion a year which
would be used for a new unemployment
insurance fund for those impacted by
Kofi Wow
what do you think about this um well
it's called the new taxes called it's
part of a new make billionaires pay
campaign how about we make the
government pay yeah that would be that
would be a great idea let's make the
government pay you want to know why we
can make the government pay because the
government put these people on the
street aren't they already paying no the
Gutner is just so we're all super clear
there's two things that we need to pay
attention to right here first of all
there's two ways that the government
steals your money one they make you pay
taxes things like federal income tax
used to not exist
they literally created that to take your
money so they can physically take the
money from you and require with the
threat of going to jail if you don't
give them the money they can put you in
jail that's the first way they take your
money
the second way and this is what they're
doing right now is they play this Mirage
of saying I'm gonna lower taxes but I'm
gonna print money when they print money
they're stealing your wealth to their
devaluing your currency and so they're
literally inflation is this hidden tax
and so that's what they've done is in
order to fund a bunch of this
unemployment and all of the stimulus
packages all this kinda stuff they're
stealing from you me and everybody else
I feel like if this law is passed
if this taxes passed all the
billionaires who live in New York and
also its kind of listen currently
taxpayers pay capital gains tax on
assets only when they sell the new
policy would tax any gain in value for
an asset during the calendar year
regardless of whether it's sold I think
that's a little supid but but um it's
like saying hey my house I bought it
like I bought an apartment for $100,000
the apartment is now because the market
went up in value worth $200,000 although
I didn't get any more money I have to
pay a tax on the change in value
literally this is the stupidest thing
I've ever
okay cool right now it's billionaires
but tomorrow could be me who is making
like not much money or suddenly I'm
paying 10 by the way hello
newsflash Socialists are coming they're
trying to implement this nonsense but
the the ultimate thing and this is where
I think people have to kind of all rally
together I don't care if you're rich
poor old young what color your skin is
what Creed's you have anything yet
religion I don't care where you are in
your life the one thing that everyone
can agree on is that billionaires they
created value and captured it for
themselves right or their families they
are some of the best capital allocators
in the world and what the politicians
want to do is take money from the best
capital allocators and put it in the
hands of the worst Caporal kids which is
the government anything the government
does is incredibly inefficient what are
the idea that we're gonna take money
from the best capital allocators and
give it to the worst capital allocators
is comical
and it all hides behind this thing of we
need to help people out know what we
need to do is for the government to get
out of the way and let the free market
run by the way you know how the
government's like oh we want everybody
we want you guys to be citizens green
cards become a citizen whatever do you
know how expensive it is to actually
become a citizen you have to be a green
card holder for five years and then pay
and pay and pay all this crap to the
government and then they send you a
Social Security card and have your name
misspelled
again it's just the idea of taking money
from the people who have created the
most value in society and then giving it
to a government who literally is
incompetent
remember they spent you want to know
where you can get a billion dollars from
here's here's a great idea they sent
over a billion dollars to dead people
with the stimulus payments billion over
a billion dollars so they want to raise
five billion dollars right there's a
billion I just found a billion hey
here's another billion why don't you go
get rid of all the bureaucracy that you
have in all these organizations
crypto banks what up the coin
billionaires Billy boys so there's
interpretive letter from the Office of
the Comptroller of the currency the OCC
which serves to charter regulate and
supervise national banks the letter
clarifies that national banks have the
authority to provide Fiat bank accounts
and cryptocurrency custodial services to
cryptocurrency businesses so isn't it
true that only like two banks could
handle crypto stuff before all this the
whole idea was most of the federally
regulated banks right there they're
rated by this OCC they would basically
say oh we can't do anything with crypto
because the OCC won't let us there's one
major change that occurred over the last
sixty days which is Brian Brooks who
used to be the chief legal officer of
coinbase
is now the head of the case the acting
Comptroller of the concert he's in
charge so there's a Bitcoin er in the
house and they let him in he was the
chief legal officer of coinbase oh yes
so now he's in charge and so he issued a
clarification he actually didn't change
anything
he just issued a clarification saying
that banks are allowed to
custody digital assets cryptocurrencies
etc and what that does now is there is
going to set off thanks you're gonna
build out custodial services things are
gonna go acquire crypto companies and
also you're gonna see crypto companies
try to create software to sell into the
banks but all we are getting to this is
huge of course this is an inflection
point again every currency will be
digital digital dollars is really end is
real euro Bitcoin Libre every currency
in the world will be digital and the
competition will not be at the
technology layer it will be at the
monetary policy layer say coin has the
superior monetary policy and Bitcoin
will be the global reserve current so
can you tell me so before if I was an
individual and I had Bitcoin I can just
deposit it in my bank yeah even worse is
not only could you not deposit it was
your bank a lot of times they would
literally shut down your account if they
saw that you're buying Bitcoin right but
now all of a sudden it's legal right and
there's a clarification saying that the
bank can hold your cryptographic keys
meaning that I can have in an account I
can't have my cash position and I got my
digital currency prism changes
everything
Flynn is gonna be a expert by the end do
I need some Bitcoin I think we were
doing all right
oh okay so wait why are you why are you
eyebrows cuz you're supposed to be the
non risk-taker I'll be the risk-taker
yeah but now that banks are so I'm like
I'm like should I convert all of the
money into Bitcoin yeah okay
what's going on with serial so new york
times will said it will acquire serial
productions the maker of the hit podcast
serial the true crime won a deal that
aims to further the newspapers
podcasting ambitions and the transaction
could be worth as much as fifty million
depending on milestones of performance
metrics and everyone's comparing this to
spotify deal with joe rogan but it's
very different Spotify was basically
acquiring a podcast or in that case a
licensing deal they've acquired a number
of other podcasts to be exclusive to
their technology platform right Spotify
is a platform not a publisher New York
Times is a publisher not a platform and
therefore my guess is that they'll keep
cereal and all the different platforms
they want as many views as possible
they're just a publisher so this is the
same thing as like buying a newsletter
buying a podcast buying you know any
sort of media property it's not
similar or comparative in my opinion to
the Spotify type deal which is an
exclusivity for a platform and kind of
gives away at what a podcast wave should
be doesn't this just drive home the idea
further that IP is important of course
eyepiece important maybe I need to go
call them New York Times well what
happened if I worked at the New York
Times I'd be fired in under 30 seconds
so yeah I mean look it's cool cereal
obviously is super super powerful I
forgot they did because I didn't listen
I only have sent about one season with
the high school kid who reportedly
killed his girlfriend I didn't listen to
the rest of them but I guess they keep
putting out new seasons right yeah I
mean look the New York Times has made a
couple of other acquisitions in the
space so it's uh it's cool to see 50
Millions a lot of money for for a media
property like that so let's see what
happens cool ready what do we have yeah
Tesla will build its next Giga factory
near Austin Texas when I have a pen it
just looks like I'm smart okay what's
going on Tesla everybody knows the truth
next Giga factory near Austin Texas so
this is yet another example of a company
slash millionaire leaving a state that
wants to tax the crap out of them no no
they're not leaving
I mean this is just a new factory so
they're not actually they're not moving
Tesla yeah he basically chose a place
that there's a couple of things I think
that Elon Musk kind of alluded to one
was the regulatory environment they're
much much more about kind of individual
freedom personal freedom and they take a
lower regulation type approach or
lighter touch regulation approach than
somebody like California they got a ton
of tax breaks to do this and there's
also a lot of talent in Austin Texas and
so I think that ultimately this is a
pretty good decision I saw a picture of
Elon Musk and Governor Abbott from Texas
and they were doing the the hook of
horns which I thought was pretty funny
actually this is the wolf pack I think
like that oh my god please get out of
your college football NC State Texas
yeah this is definitely that's
okay so you see how Oklahoma takes place
in the comments yesterday this is 40
Gators so stupid that when you do so
yesterday in the comments a lot of
people said they wanted us to move to
Austin Texas which I personally am NOT
opposed to we're gonna go look hey so
don't we tell in our secrets we're gonna
go look oh my god I'm never telling you
anything what's up what's up I love I
love this quote from musk he said we're
gonna make it a factory that's gonna be
stunning it's right on the Colorado
River we're actually gonna have a
boardwalk over you biking hiking trails
it's gonna basically be an ecological
paradise look what does he think he's
going to the jungle yeah exactly
who cares so funny Tesla is the future
duh electric vehicles are obviously
gonna overtake gasoline vehicles so
whatever we're all gonna be going up by
a cyber truck we're going to electric e
Formula One races what would you do if I
had a cyber truck alright what's going
on astronauts what's going on NASA
astronauts on historic SpaceX mission
aiming for an August 2nd return so my
question is are they gonna ride the same
SpaceX thing or like another SpaceX
thing no they're gonna build another one
in space and then come back on video but
I don't know maybe now says something
else no they're coming back on the same
one they're strapped into SpaceX crew
Dragon capsule people watched as they
were strapped the crazy part is not that
many Peter one likes the launches but I
feel like we should celebrate the
returning as much as the launch right
there days conducting spacewalks to
upgrade the Space Station's hardware as
well as handling scientific experiments
designed for the microgravity
environment on the board onboard the
station it's so I love that they do
science in space same I mean that's kind
of how we got the space with science but
it's a whole nother thing and they what
I don't know is I think the capsule if I
remember correctly it falls into the
ocean like the basically as if as it
comes back and falls
normally and there's a and there's a
parachute and then it lands in the water
but I thought that nah
got it where is the rocket oh the rocket
already came back oh right but because
when you shoot the rocket up then
basically the capsule keeps going the
rocket falls away you just like let it
go into the ocean and pollute it like
that no they go and they get up there
yeah we just let them fall in the oceans
ask room see you guys later
no problem alright so oh no no what
happened so okay so there's this thing
this woman went on shark tank back in
2009 and her pitch was something called
face block and it was these like fun
face masks that would go over like when
you're sick order when swine flu was in
the news in 2009 and then their surgical
masks with designs on them and then and
then looking back now she said if we
could predict the future we could all be
rich
I miss classic right right idea wrong
time yeah so I mean that's what happens
timing and which market you choose is
almost more important than anything else
yeah like you can have a bad idea or a
not great idea and a not great team pick
the right market at the right time and
you'll still be successful you could
have a fantastic team and a fantastic
idea pick the wrong market or the wrong
time and you fail so like I don't know
if she's good or not I don't if the idea
was good or not but just facemasks in
2020 is a way better timing then phase
mess in 2008 it said she pitched the
right product just in the wrong decade
and while her face masks are suddenly
sadly not available for purchase she has
a line of only in Silicon Valley
greeting cards you can buy so she fitted
pivoted to greeting cards after she was
stuck with the face masks imagine if she
was sitting there just ready to roll
with a whole box full of n95 masks
alright let's go oh wait before you say
the joke by the way we didn't put this
in here in topics but unemployment
numbers today there have now been 52
point 5 million Americans who have lost
their job in the last four and a half
months around in four and a half months
52 million Americans have lost their
jobs that means one in three people lost
their jobs over the last four and a half
months absolutely insanity
hopefully as we reopen economies people
will get their jobs back there are not
52 people 52 million people sitting at
home right now without a job some of
them have gotten their jobs back half
start to go back to work found new jobs
whatever but absolutely you know just
breathtaking number in terms of how many
people have been out of work and the
last four and half months sad all right
what's your joke my joke is why don't I
tell jokes why don't I tell jokes they'd
crack each other up
why don't scientists trust that why
don't scientists trust atoms what cuz
they make everything up see it's not
funny it's not who's the deliver either
it's just they're not funny jokes when
you google world's funniest joke I
promise you they're not funny why
because you're reading them off of the
internet what you need is you need like
good jokes knock knock who's there
orange orange you special guy this is
what I deal with every day on a daily
basis all right before I forget
aren't you gonna leave me alone now yes
thank you lunch money that's it for
today well while she's trying to get
rich rest of us trying to get her lunch
money right please please please
subscribe to the channel I want to get
to a hundred thousand subscribers by the
end of August let's go fifteen fifteen
thousand subscribers to go let's go get
me to a hundred Kay I'll be so happy
just do it for me cuz then he'll be
happy he won't know it was for me [ __ ]
see you guys tomorrow what do you do
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block mines my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got 3
products they can give you a u.s. dollar
loan you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account or you can buy and sell crypto
occur
he's on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6 percent
interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but 8.6
percent it's pretty compelling so click
on the link in the description say
thanks to the folks that block by
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy plan in the comment and we'll see
you guys tomorrow and be kind to your
friends